you already know it is your boy Joe
Moses man check me out on the bootleg
calf podcast
bootleg cash show special guests in here
going crazy with this new single yes sir
featuring Jeremiah's called freak it
yeah the album comes out September 30th
yeah
we got Joe Moses yeah one of these La
pillars in here man come on man you know
you know who inspired album too that
[ __ ] Jizzle
who YG oh he did we had a show the other
night in Orange County do you guys see
album coming out the same day so you
guys that's a good day for LA Hip Hop
we ran into each other at the show
and we was backstage just chopping it up
you know what I'm saying and we just was
chopping it up just about what we need
to be doing as far as me and him like
nobody else doing it me and you need to
be doing this and you're like I'm
driving on 30 I said [ __ ] I'm gonna drop
only 30 or two he said bro we got to
like you know what I'm saying and that
was yeah I mean you YG Ty we were just
talking a bit like you guys really are
like an era of this La [ __ ] like you
guys really kept La alive first the
goats a very long time I think I think
it's it's at an era where it's like let
me take that back
um
YG and Ty didn't accomplished more than
me so I'm not going to even put that
goat thing on myself I'm real like
honest and real YG mustard and Ty have
accomplished a lot more than Joe Moses
so I'm not the goat you know I'm saying
I'm I'm just a staple I'm a factor
you're a pillar definitely so that's I'm
I'm so hard on myself bro like you know
I mean um
for all the good reasons though you know
I'm saying Ice Cube is the goat Dr Dre
is the goat Snoop Dogg is to go too
short E40 the mark goats DJ Quick those
are those we just and I could say Ty and
and YG and mustard have accomplished way
more than Joe Moses so I can I can call
them the goats too I'm not afraid to get
my friends their props of course I'm the
next one to have that ghost status I was
gonna tell like like what has been going
on the last couple of years because I
totally didn't was it
it's been two or three years that you've
dropped No Effects
um you've been doing so much you've been
building up the youth football program
yeah you've been launching businesses
yeah you have a restaurant yeah you got
the shoe company yeah
um but you've I mean clearly you've also
been recording a lot but yeah I feel
like you've just been kind of a little
bit more focused on building a bunch of
other [ __ ] outside of rap is that safe
to say yeah it's safe to say that I want
to have something to fall back on which
is smart and I I need I started
um I've wasted a lot of money so you
know the 40s and the 30s and 100 000s
that you get 200 000 I start thinking
real smart and thinking positive with
this money instead of me blowing it in
the club every night and not
accomplishing nothing but a beer belly
let me start investing my my money yeah
yeah so like
first of all the shoes crazy this is a
very like I can't even wrap my head
around what it would take to like create
a shoe yeah how hard is that like do you
have to go find like manufacturers yeah
like are they coming from Asia like
actually they are it says made in China
yeah so so my boy was a close friend to
me he used to work at LRG he called me
and said his family I ain't gonna say
his name because everybody try taking
blood so he called me it was like my
family dude shoes they'll be out here do
you want to do a shoot you you always
used to talk about you want to do a shoe
you have a design I had this design five
years ago okay and I'm like
um we sat down we had a meeting and we
put the whole play together and I sent
him my first idea my first idea
basically was like
I want to do a fashionable
I want to do a fashionable shoe a Chuck
but something to my culture like a Dior
like a Chuck you know what I mean I want
to put them both together that's why you
got the big the big top that's why you
don't have the black thing right here
that's why you got the Ugg kind of feel
in the inside it's so comfortable on the
inside you know what I'm saying so I
never spent like 75
80 000 just on my samples damn you know
I'm saying just getting everything
together it's a hard business to get
into we always hear people do a clothing
line the shoe line is like it's such a
[ __ ] hard thing to break into because
there's just the big dogs so you think
Joe Moses put out a shoe like
you like to but you see the details in
this [ __ ] like it's detailed like so
where do you sell these at on my own I
got a store okay so we got a store in
Bellflower
um
we sell them on on the internet and we
sell them on our website we sell them in
the store at my shows and my concerts
are you trying to get them in like Chic
or I would love to get them in Chic I
would love to get them in bloomies I
would love I mean zoomy's um
Bloomingdale's I would love to get them
in in the big spots I haven't reached
that
or I don't know anybody that reached out
to me yet but I sell these shoes for two
hundred dollars [ __ ] that's a win you
know what I'm saying oh yeah backpacks
everything going up and and not only do
I do shoes though so I'm big in the
football Community also so I sell clicks
black back flaps mouthpieces gloves you
know and that's what I'm trying to get
my partners on like bro well because you
are for people who don't know you're not
just big into football I mean you're
kind of one of those guys when it comes
to the youth football in La it's a it's
a the new generation it's a couple of
guys and you're coaching you're you have
teams under you you're helping develop
these kids like um first of all how did
that even like get started because I
mean we always hear Snoop you know who's
kind of the guy who like we look to in
that world but like you've been on it
for so Snoop is the kind of guy that
looked up to like
my dad you know my dad coached football
and bass and people from just different
places we all looked up to somebody and
then you got to think like Snoop was
around when I was a kid coaching youth
football his kids was around Rolling
Heights Raiders so we would see
that and I never thought I was to be a
rapper back then you know I'm saying I
was a football player right I played
football played basketball baseball so I
was just an athlete my Pops I seen the
way my pops
um ventured off to this and it kept him
out the way and kept him my pops had a
free mind when football season came you
know what I'm saying so this kept my
pops alive nice like damn this thing
really want to coach football these kids
with you what you see in this and it's
really fun you know what I'm saying and
that was my fulfilling too right it's
fun man it's fulfilling and I'm like
giving back in my own way and you know
these kids don't know me as Joe Moses
they know me at Coach Joe you know I'm
saying and I started my own chapter I
just went off on the limb first and
foremost I put in work with the chapter
I grew up playing with you know I'm
definitely big on loyalty so I went back
to the same chapter I grew up playing
with Wow and it was my family still was
running the chapter and um
I stayed there for like five or six
years and we didn't have our different
differences it's just I wanted something
different and they was a little bit
older and they didn't see my vision and
then I started my own chapter I didn't
hate I didn't do anything I just you
know got Their Blessings you know what I
wanted you know we going different ways
and how the vision supposed to look I
didn't put in work these last five years
let me just go in my own way and I'm
gonna start a chapter but I'm gonna
still be in the same league can I get
y'all blessings they gave me the
blessings I went on started the LA
Chiefs and the rest is history I put in
the work the first two years we took ass
whoopings and people laughed at us I
came in the room Hey Joe what you want
to do
um I bet 100 push-ups we whoop y'all ass
whoo I'm like hey I'm like that okay I
took my ass whoopings the first two
first year I took my ass whoopings and
Snoop
the next year was pandemic pandemic I
still play football
at the pandemic we whooped everybody out
we went we traveled we played travel
ball we went
um Vegas we went to Arizona we went to
San Francisco we went to the Bay Area
Sacramento we went to Texas we played
like real football you know what I'm
saying so I got that experience we ended
up being a ranked team and then
the next year Snoop opened back up
because Snoop wasn't opened up in
pandemic we they opened back up and the
rest is history you beat Snoop yeah yeah
yeah you know what's up huh you know
what's up and we played we played on the
17th that that Super Bowl game we played
the first game of the season oh and
Snoop against Snoop team
because snoop's not like you're a little
bit more Hands-On at this point than
Snoop is right because snoop's got so
much [ __ ] going on yeah yeah pretty you
were like yo I'd love to come to the
club but I have a game this time this
time this time yeah so you coaching
because for people who don't know so
like if you have a chapter is it like
within that chapter there's a team for
each age group yeah so we got so my
chapter got seven teams we got six you
we got eight you we got two Au teams we
got a nine you we got a 10 you we got 11
you and a 12 you and on those uh uh I
think out of all those teams I coach on
four teams damn I coach 9u 10U 11U and
12u and so you're busy and and I I mean
I'm a president my one of my best
friends is the coach on 6u and 8U so he
went down from coaching on my team the
coach and he was successful last year we
won three Champions three championships
last year your chapter yeah we went we
went to we won two Nationals last year
and we've we've just like we got
National ranked teams like we've beaten
national rank number one in the nation
team so I got about four teams in my
chapter that's ranked nationally that's
crazy you know what I'm saying like
number one in the nation number number
three in the nation number four in
California number number you know I'm
saying [ __ ] like that so we've been
building man shout out to my whole
chapter shout out to my parents my
coaches my staff and my kids they love
I'm talking about I got Chief kids Chief
babies they don't want to be nothing
else because in this new Dan air in this
new you football
everybody want to combine and join
forces it's kind of like the rap game
yeah when you hot they they messing with
you when you cold they not so you got
parents that's like well y'all don't win
I ain't I'm taking my baby somewhere
else you're not teaching the kids
nothing all right yeah I teach them how
to push through adversity and get better
and I got parents that's been with me
since we're taking them ass whoopings
and then we just added more kids we not
a chapter either that accept all the
great kids I might accept all alignments
but skills I don't want I want to
develop the kids that I got and you got
a lot of you got a lot of hate in in the
football Society we ain't gonna go I can
imagine I can admit bro listen
especially on me I can imagine there
ain't nothing like uh
parents whose kids play sports they I
ain't gonna lie to you bro the the
things that I see and the things that
I'm subjective to see I'll be sitting
there like and I'm I'm so indebted in it
because I love it like it's a passion
for me it's more of a piece it's more
leaving the streets when I get to
practice like um I love seeing my babies
like I love seeing my kids these are my
kids but you got so much hate that they
put on Joe Moses and it's just like
we've made so much of an impact these
last couple of years they gonna hate and
a lot of people are they not they're not
ready for that a lot of people in my
chapter be like man I'll be like bro
that's just we successful we got the
best chapter in California period
anybody will tell you anybody in youth
football there but like the Chiefs for
hands down family orientated the way
they move the way their parents are like
we got the best chapter and and chief
football what is the wildest [ __ ] you've
seen from a parent at a game
um
at a parent at a game because we always
see like viral videos of like parents
fighting or someone just there's a lot
of crazy [ __ ] going on yeah probably
fighting you know what I'm saying
fighting I've seen I've seen teams lose
and parents fight each other I've seen
I've seen a lot in youth football like I
won't go really into it because I want
to put a bad stigma on you for you
football especially in in the chapter
that win that's why I feel it's more of
a family orientated like you take a loss
we'll be in the parking lot still
popping you know but outside of that
outside of that's where I feel right no
disrespect to nobody else I'm just not
as passionate for outside of syfl like I
love that's why I feel I'm all for syfl
Snoop you with snoopers has done for me
I will never you know I'm saying never
leave his side I would never try to
start my own like he's done a lot for me
and always giving me the game and wisdom
and always you know everybody else like
I got love for everybody else outside of
Snoop but the family orientated outside
of snoopers like chaos oh really yeah
shoot man yeah outside of Snoop you know
I'm just being honest with you it's like
okay it's like chaotic like everybody's
like every man for themselves and that's
not like you know I'm saying I'm for the
kids you know what I'm saying and I'm
passionate about it like if you your son
was on my team and you leave my team I
might not talk to you for six months
Jesus I'm just passionate about my kids
and and I built my kid it's a difference
when you build your kids right like I
built I built like you get you football
now it's like you build a kid and as you
building a kid it's like they get the
success and then another another coach
might see them now but they're on a
better team and come on over here come
on over here and because we losing over
here it's like I built this kid nobody
believed in this kid like I built this
kid now all of a sudden you want to take
the kids away from me you know what I'm
saying so it's kind of bad it's kind of
bad but it's a great thing I can imagine
I'll be stressed out
um we're talking about obviously you
know the era of mustard time yeah yeah
YG who Do you look to as like
the current day version of that in LA
um
of us or is there is that even exist I
can't even I can't even put no I can't
even put no title on nobody yet right
but I love what everybody is doing yeah
obviously there's been artists who've
had like crazy individual success like
karate Rich so blast but I just mean in
terms of I don't know if there's like a
there's no movement a real unit no so so
at the bottom so let me speak on that so
why I say that is because
before YG was cracking he had push ink
right you know what I'm saying before
Joe Moses cracking I had aob you know
what I'm saying it was it was those two
units and everybody else in between you
at a2y you had Layman crack ready with
AV that got the money dance
it was us
we built we we used to be in parties
together going crazy in the parties it
was a movement they had their crew we
had our crew they had their crew and we
went to park like we didn't care about
Hollywood we was in the in the in the
trenches in a hot ass function going
crazy you know so I'm saying so I
haven't seen nobody do that like these
people are getting success off of what
we built think about it everybody
learned from our mistakes so they jump a
lot of people jump the line that don't
mean they ain't worked right I'm not
saying that because blast I definitely
knew blast back in the day last was with
tiu he was with a crew yeah you
understand what I'm saying and um but
everybody else like like learn okay I
want to do that boom boom boom and got
on like that we really was like in the
trenches like sweating in hot ass hot
parties and really going crazy I also
too feel like uh you guys early on made
like a concerted effort to like make
like function music that's that's what
it was because we was in the functions
it was like yo you guys made records
that like I mean damn I mean do it for
the ratchets is you know all time
[ __ ] they don't they don't even they
don't even treat Joe Moses like I'm a
goat you know I mean you said you
weren't the ghost okay they don't even
treat me like
like you ain't Joe Moses man you'll get
a promoter and be like Hey Joe can we
get you for 1500 I'll be like bro did
you just see this DJ post all these hits
of myself I just saw that yeah shout out
to him too uh that DJ he's I forget his
Charlie he'd be posting all the LA [ __ ]
come on they're the greatest hits I got
mad at him too and I'm not mad at him
literally like like I say I'm not the
goat everybody don't deserve a greatest
hits because you're not there yet
everybody don't deserve that
the problem is now we putting everybody
in the same situations in the same
categories right you know so everybody
don't deserve that that look yet you
know what I'm saying some some people
you got to save for I've been in it 11
10 11 years some people you got to save
for their 10th Year where are you gonna
be at your 10th year I can still say I'm
still right here with Booth leg care
yeah putting out music putting out
successful music I'm still consistent
everybody don't deserve that right I
never told him this but I was sitting
there like bro
everybody don't deserve a a a a a
greatest hits a tick tock everybody
don't deserve it Greatest Hits I mean
it's like a tick tock it's a cool
Tick-Tock idea he's trying to help out
L.A you know it's not bad I I ain't mad
at it I'm not mad at it but I just I
just don't like when people put other
people in the same categories like you
know who I'm I like right now is like
obviously the blue bucks guys because
they're making dope Club records and I
feel like they're very like uh
if they just sound to me like really
unique they got a unique flow they got a
unique way that they're doing [ __ ]
they're my guys Drake just co-signed him
which was dope they don't listen we love
Drake but it was co-signed before Drake
for sure Joe Moses co-side for sure
that's L.A let me ask you this somebody
who
is a la pillar how much did it help when
you had guys like a future come in and
co-sign like what you were doing
officially just made it better for the
women the women was like a whole future
for messing with Joe
it just makes the eye look better and
that's sad though I was I was a somebody
before future came and said anything but
future put more light on Joe Moses you
know what I'm saying like but it's sad
in your own area where
like promoters didn't open up to me
until future came would start coming to
my my clubs with me or I start I start
thugs start pulling up with me him and
gonna start jumping out of the club so
they're like Hey Joe we want to book
jomos for this party this party too
cause Gunner might show up Thug my show
G herbo might show up Ty Dollar Sign
might show up like bro I've been
bringing out the whole city for years
and years at a time it's only facts like
you know what I mean like I speak facts
what do you feel uh like right now
because like since the pandemic came and
went a bunch of Clubs closed then I feel
like The Nightlife scene is kind of
it's interesting in LA right now how do
you feel about it I mean I you know a
div is my brother I talked to a d the
other day and I was I was so frustrated
with him he like what and that's my
brother when I say this I'm passionate
enough to say it because like I love
these guys like a d i i he probably one
of the only people I come in the club he
like bro don't spend no money tonight I
got you you know so I'm saying so we
need people like that but I was
frustrated with him the other day and I
texted me like La function you coming
and I'm like I don't see myself on no
flyer
you're like brother I've been waiting on
you to come I I try to set up with your
manager I'm like bro you have La
function without the LA guys
right
like how you have an LA function without
la
I think uh was this the one that was
just a bunch of DJs I don't know what it
was but because they know they did an LA
function and it was like I am L.A tons
of DJs I didn't see any artists on it
maybe I'm tripping right I am when I say
this
I'm respected because I speak truth and
I speak reality I don't come on no
microphone and bootleg cave show to
speak down on anybody else I just speak
the truth I am L.A it's only facts it's
only a couple of people that really
represent la like
bro there's no way in hell why you doing
the LA function that I'm not on the LA
function or the guys that do represent
La the right way it's on the LA function
there's nowhere in hell that could that
be because maybe they don't know
because look at the end of the day like
I said you've been building up so much
of the [ __ ] no that's cap freak it's
been out for two months month and a half
I came to the LA function and spent some
dough I just mean in terms of like
maybe you're not put like like it would
make sense if you put out some music
yeah at the same time or if you had
music out like
I just I just I I've been like just a
nobody put music out that was that they
was booking I thought it was all DJs
they have blue books they have blue
books the first day I'm thinking of that
of the day he's thinking about there was
like the big La function festival and it
was just all DJs yeah they had blue
books the first day
blue books is from L.A they have blue
books the first day I'm talking about
they had a beta La too so they had
Kamaya you know what I'm saying but I'm
talking about I don't think they're on
the flyer even with no music out who
don't want to come see two hours of job
I can perform for two hours
right I got hits like
I just think that like at least the
Flyers I've seen have been all DJs I
don't think they were booking Talent
maybe I'm telling you for sure I knew
they were just
yeah I think fools were just pulling up
that's that's what makes it bad RJ
that's what I'm saying he got he got he
don't have to drop tomorrow he got
consistent records to still turn up the
LA function I think they booked I just
think they booked DJs no I'm telling you
they not you you wanna
lighters that's what I mean
it was Brian Sampson been blowing you up
nah he blowing you up yo I'm in the
middle of an interview bud what the [ __ ]
can I do for you
where you at are you outside do you need
someone to let you in Brian Sampson
[ __ ] off then
Jesus Christ
the guy you got to hang around with
working your record that's [ __ ] fat
shout out to Brian [ __ ] Brian
working my record like a month he is
working your record
um hey what up it's bootleg cab we gotta
stop the interview to tell you what our
good friends at my bookie football
season has started my favorite time of
the year because I love to gamble on
football it makes watching football so
much fun it's my like literally I just
love watching football and I love it
even more when I got money on the line
and no matter where you are right now
what state what country you can get in
on the action it's winning season go to
my bookie sign up for a new account
register and get that double deposit
bonus using the promo code bootleg now
let me tell you what that means that
means when you go to my bookie let's say
you make a 250 deposit using the promo
code bootleg you'll have 500 to gamble
with that's right they're gonna double
your [ __ ] money right now they got
the prop builder you could bet on uh
whether or not I don't know what Matthew
Stafford throw for three touchdowns will
Kyler Murray rush for a touchdown you
could put all those on one thing and
secure the [ __ ] bag all right
get online with your boy let's get this
money together my bookie go sign up with
that promo code bootleg and double your
deposit right now go register talk about
uh this new record obviously
taking the old school was it easy to get
the sample cleared yeah
yeah you're not and
yeah corrupt my brother I know baby yes
I know battle cat yeah easy lay up
together that's family and if they don't
clear no records I'm you just knock on
the door yeah I'll be at the house I
also run into peaceful I feel like I run
into corrupt more than anyone else I'd
just be at Hooters I'll be at just
wherever I'm at I feel like corrupt
somehow is there at the same time
corrupt is one of my favorite rappers oh
for sure top five no streets is a mother
one of my favorite albums ever top five
patrice's mother's crazy top five
they're calling out names come on man
come on man see see that is like come on
man that's legendary that's legendary
for me for the city that's legendaries
and it's a lot of other legendary guys
that never made it as big as corrupt did
but still was Staples in the city that
you probably never heard of like the
relatives I know about their relatives
yeah man the Eastsiders come on I'm just
saying but a lot of people don't know
about these these individuals huh
both the East Side his albums were crazy
come on man see I grew up off that type
of music and be brazy um a legend I'm
talking about where I come from Legend
you know what I'm saying Figaro Rider
gang like that I grew up off that type
of like I was in the streets do you uh
like for you do you kind of feel like
the same way like
those guys didn't get the love maybe
like the do you feel like you're kind of
in that same position for your era
listen I come from a hood that's most
hated first and foremost
we the only bloods in this little
community and we most hate it you know
what I'm saying so just where I come
from we beef with everybody it's no it's
no control we beef with everybody and
just off that Vibe now me being a man
and building my own relationships like
my relationships are crazy so me being a
man but it's a lot of [ __ ] that don't
give me my just do just why can't why I
come just because of where you're from
just from where I'm from they'd be like
nope well I want to hear it [ __ ] her
[ __ ] and that's just it is what it is
and people a lot of people are like nah
Joe Moses really [ __ ] got bars he
really can flow and he really talking a
real story a lot of these [ __ ] is
fabricating right you meet artists that
that you know a lot of artists be
fabricating in their music I've really
been in prison and I don't make me a
bigger person or a tougher person but my
stories are authentic and 1000 a lot of
people just rapping it's a lot of rap
and rap just rapping the rap speaking of
that what were your thoughts coming from
the culture here in LA
when you see this quando Rondo kid go on
Instagram and say driving his flag he's
dropping his flag
I felt like it's usually not that easy
right man [ __ ] don't work like that [ __ ]
yeah man born in this [ __ ] [ __ ] you
talking about dropping your flag hey get
off the end and get off the internet and
go do what you need to do and I'm
talking about anybody that think this
gang banging this [ __ ] is easy man
listen ain't nobody bigger than the
program see the fact is you get money
you think you bigger than the program
you're not you still got rules and
regulations that you got to go by it's
still somebody that I got to answer to
regardless if I got millions
right and he's not even he's not from
here so I think he probably don't even
understand like what he really signed up
for you don't know what you signed and
that's the problem with these artists
well people be like oh well
oh well six nine he ain't this he didn't
know man that man was caught man listen
you know what you sign up for
taking on the chin get in the field and
get ready like that's why I don't I
don't come here and say because the fans
ain't like I'm like Joe Moses still
promoting gang banging it no you're not
I'm just telling you the real I know
what I signed up for every day when I
walk outside if I go to a restaurant and
eat with my family and somebody see me
over there I know what I signed up for
Angel hey man this [ __ ] Joe Mo's up
here eating with his family come up here
like that [ __ ] like that happened so you
got to be prepared for everything that
you signed up for and I know when I'm
coaching football bro I'm I I know what
I signed up for I just can't be just
forgetful of what happened in my past
and like I'm just coaching football and
nobody won't come and be sitting down
the street and waiting for me to pull
off and and bust 12 shots into my car
and try to kill me like bro you have to
know what you signed up for this [ __ ] I
don't think people really understand
what they trying to rap and they trying
to be from a section and they think they
get money and they think they bigger
than the program ain't no man bigger
than the program like nobody's bigger
than the pro I don't care if you got 30
million bro you're not bigger than the
program bro you still got to answer to
somebody it's still little homies over
there that's making sure that you able
to still come over here so what you
gonna do and I don't and I'm and not to
say it like that I don't even associate
myself
with with negativity I associate myself
with all positivity first and foremost
you know what I'm saying but I know what
I signed up for I love my homies win
lose a draw you know what I'm saying I'm
never gonna come up here and talk bad
about my homies and my section I'm never
gonna be like oh I got money and them
[ __ ] can't I love my homies like at
certain points in my life sometimes I
just separate myself and just do my own
thing that don't mean I don't love my
hood right I love my homies that just
mean I'm just oh I'm on my grind I'm on
my Grizzy I'm on my game I'm trying to
I'm trying to make it make it I'm not
trying to be having businesses I'm
trying to make it like puffy like Jay-Z
and I'm not trying to be no trying to
halfway make it or like neighborhood
make it or else I'm not trying to I'm
trying to be worldwide successful like
you know what I'm saying owning my own
liquor and doing my own thing and and
and and I say a person that made it that
a person won't even look look at to like
we we say Jay-Z and we say puffy right
I'm trying to make it like Snoop I'm
trying to make it like E40 E40 got his
own liquor killing him he's got his own
liquor he's got his own ice cream he has
his own lumpia company come on bro he's
got like I just don't look up to his
wine he's got the [ __ ] Turf burritos
I just don't look up to them Staples
because like I say I was born and raised
where nine to five was special like you
know what I'm saying like everybody got
their Lane of how you supposed to do
stuff my grandfather who worked like I
still look up to him like you don't got
to have be successful and have a job and
I mean we're making million dollars for
me not to look at you taking care of
your family is successful for me and
that's my main that's my main goal you
know what I'm saying
are there any uh mistakes that you feel
like you said earlier that you guys laid
the groundwork for a lot of the new
generation with some of the mistakes you
made what were those mistakes you feel
like you made throughout your music
career that you'd look back on and be
like damn my pride my pride um
being upset getting myself upset I made
a lot of mistakes you know what I'm
saying even with even with you know
mustard you know I'm saying like me and
mustard ain't talked to years and that's
my brother I always wish him nothing but
success you know what I'm saying but I
can talk about it now because like I say
it's always going to be my brother I
love him and it ain't no issues I'm sure
guys his original falling out it wasn't
no it wasn't no falling out I just I
just was I just was in my pride and I'm
a man to admit like when I'm wrong and
talking to the wrong people you know
what I'm saying and people keeping it
Stir It Up and I'm like [ __ ] it and he
trying to like have conversations I'm
like nah [ __ ] in the rinse like bro
like why are you so upset like you know
I'm saying this [ __ ] is business at the
end of the day keep that [ __ ] going and
keep that [ __ ] successful and it [ __ ]
up a lot of relationships dealing with
my pride dealing with pride and and
dealing with younger artists like I I
had one take Jay that was then was my
guys then was around me we played
basketball for months and months at a
time great guy and dealing with my pride
like he like big bro what should I do
I'm taking the uh they want a meeting
with me and I'm like [ __ ] you going
beside me trying to do a meeting move
and I just cut him off and like [ __ ]
like that dealing with my pride is like
[ __ ] me up in a lot of situations where
it's like bro why you so why you so
upset like get it together and now that
I'm older I can admit my faults and say
Joe Moses have made a lot of mistakes
dealing with pride
what do you think because a lot of
people it takes like some sort of I mean
I've had I used to you know probably
used to get in the way of a lot of [ __ ]
I used to look at other people and what
they were doing and make it feel some
type of way about what I had going on or
like you said like I'd be like man [ __ ]
them like or I used to really give a
[ __ ] if like
Somebody went to like the other person's
radio show yeah like you know what I
mean but I'm like I don't care about
none of this [ __ ] no more I'm like bro
I'm doing me there's enough money for
everybody but I feel you like was there
something that happened that like really
made you kind of reevaluate that [ __ ]
this is like life is too short losing
these ass uh losing DJ official losing
my father losing my uncle I lost about
since pandemic I lost about 19 people
you know so I'm saying losing people I
don't want to lose my friends like you
know we might not see eye to eye every
day but losing my friends on something
that's not even important I've lost real
people to me to the left and to the
right and I'm looking I'll be like damn
I don't have nobody crazy I don't like I
don't have my father like that's that's
a big thing for me not being having
nobody to talk to sometimes I need
guidance right so I got my my godfather
you you know I call him and make
conversations to him I got my football
friends I got my homies you ever talk
about going to therapy
yeah hey cause look you're the head of
your household no no no no you're a
leader for so many people but who do you
have to no no no that's facts see see
I'm not I'm not afraid of it and I'm not
I'm not against it like you know what
I'm saying like I've talked to somebody
I was like maybe Joe you need to go to
therapy you've lost so much and you
bundle this [ __ ] all in it's not it's
not about someone to talk and we have to
stop that narrative too thinking that in
our black homes thinking that you know
that's that's because that's what goes
on in Black home we don't need no
[ __ ] therapy you don't need to
go talk to nobody ain't nothing wrong
with your punk ass trust me they said
not just black homes why white trash
home as well
that's something that we go through
[ __ ] dad needs therapy that
[ __ ] would never go though nah I
I've got so much bottled in bro and
people really don't understand like I
deal with a lot of issues and a lot of
problems and I sometimes I look up and I
don't have nobody to help me with
nothing if you ever tried mushrooms no
that [ __ ] might change your language I
might go shoot up
[Music]
misconception nope that's not true
that's not true how are you feeling
therapeutic it's therapeutic it's
therapeutic they actually they're
pushing for uh
psilocybin which is the active
ingredient in mushrooms they're pushing
for psilocybin uh therapy Joe Biden's
trying to get it legalized in the next
two years it's already legal in Portland
like in Portland you go to psychiatrists
and they'll put you like they'll give
you psilocybin in a dose and then work
with you through it's it's trust me do
some research is that if you eat a ton
of anything you're going to trip balls
but like trust me shrooms is the [ __ ]
future man I've been hearing it it is
the future I've been in a gang of Studio
sessions with some big artists you saw
Meek Mill just tweeted about it yeah but
I've been I've been in some big
producers and big artists with [ __ ]
like Hey Y'all let's get off these
mushrooms and make these beats and I'm
like
[ __ ] that I ain't doing none of that
[ __ ] I ain't cause I [ __ ] want to
kill all you [ __ ] in this [ __ ]
I can't control I can't even control
weed but but it's a little more
controllable like eating eating weed is
dangerous yeah if you eat weed too much
it's [ __ ]
if you eat too much mushrooms you're
just going to change your life in a
positive way
don't listen to him he has no idea what
he said he's a he's a
appreciate y'all watching but listen our
partners at Blue chew they got you
handled fellas and Etc whatever you are
they got it if you got a dick Bluetooth
is for you because they will make sure
your dick performs at all time levels I
I mean like LeBron LeBron his first
three seasons with the heat type levels
I mean your wife will thank you for it
everybody will thank you for it [ __ ]
even if you just take a Bluetooth and
jerk your dick it's a it's a stronger
jerk I swear to God stronger [ __ ] jerk
for sure you're gonna be beating your
dick like a stole something so what you
got to do is go to bluetooth.com right
now use the promo code bootleg right now
and you're gonna get your first month
free and this is the great thing about
Bluetooth the same active ingredients as
Viagra and essialis
but uh you don't got to go to the
doctor's office yeah who wants to go
hang out at the doctor's office and be
like hey Doc you got some [ __ ] pills for
me nobody wants to do that no you sign
up at Blue use the promo code bootleg
and you're getting your first month
delivered to your door in discreet
packaging I'm telling you you're gonna
thank me later all right if you've
gotten Bluetooth already just DM me tell
me just just DM me no photos just tell
me how you know let me just tell you
it's [ __ ] amazing our producer
Cyrus's daddy 70 took the Bluetooth he's
[ __ ] just beating down all the senior
citizen [ __ ] available in Arizona right
now so go to bluetooth.com use that
promo code bootleg or just hit the link
in the description of this video let's
get back to the interview
um you know I always wanted to know this
um
a song like paranoid comes out the label
puts Bob on it you're on the original
yeah at the time I'm sure you felt some
type of way but like I didn't talk to
tie for months behind this [ __ ] yeah
tell me what happened there because I
remember like having the OG version of
my Serato and then obviously the version
that the label works because Bob was on
fire as a label made you know again back
to the music business
I didn't [ __ ] with time for that and
Tyler's my brother you know I didn't
[ __ ] with him I'm like [ __ ] I'll show
up to the video shoot like thinking it
was our video shooting it was Bob there
I'm like
I'm like what the [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
interesting [ __ ] ass [ __ ] well that's
how me and Todd talk to each other but
that's my brother though don't get it
[ __ ] up but I'm like you guys look
like you could also literally be
brothers yeah that's my that's really my
brother I was with him last night like I
don't give a [ __ ] what he do I'm gonna
[ __ ] what he got going on that's the
situation I had to get over to and then
I just got so much respect for LA radio
DJ e-man I got so much love for just
different people at Power and and Philly
played that version they like man Joe
most version better yeah we're gonna
play We sticking behind Joe Moses you
know what I'm saying like even when
people think I'm taking shots at TI I'm
like nah I'm not taking shots but that
was [ __ ] I shouldn't say something
like that about a man's wife you know so
I'm saying and I I'm older to admit that
now I mean listen I was just rapping
though you were just rapping and
sometimes when you're just rapping you
just be saying some [ __ ] I was just
talking everybody listen to my music
they they hear I say all type of [ __ ] so
I was just rapping it wasn't no shot at
T.I like I was just rapping and it's
like not like you knew TI at the time
yeah I was just rapping bro it wasn't it
wasn't it wasn't personal you know what
I'm saying everybody thought it was
personal everybody like oh you taking
shots
one of my favorite [ __ ] urban legend is
one of my favorite albums in the world
like what you talking about like it
could be his best it's best that one of
trap music come on both you know what
I'm saying like trap music hey let's get
away let's get a room on the other side
of town urban legend like you gotta stop
yeah ASAP these kids together man that
one kid is [ __ ] turned up you don't
gotta do nothing man look at how you
spoke no I like how he spoke on it
though you know what he said he said I
gave him all the game I could give him
it's up to him now he's gonna have to go
to jail or something and my daddy told
me the same exact thing you know I went
to prison
just because you grew up a certain way
you can't coddle like a kid I like how
T.I responded to all the backlash
because he was like yo like
yo I I told him everything I could tell
him it's on him now so you got all these
[ __ ] on the internet that's
that's that's that's that's
focus on what we doing in life really
Instagram you should be charging these
[ __ ]
a [ __ ] a monthly fee to be able to
say all this negative [ __ ] to us right
you know what I'm saying we should
charge on Instagram if you want to see
my life [ __ ] I should be able to
charge you to see my life they have that
it's called only fans yeah but I'm
talking about my real I'm talking about
on this Instagram [ __ ] right if that
life technically you can do that on IG
now yeah you can uh you people can
subscribe to your page uh for like
exclusive content that only goes to your
subscribers on IG so technically not my
points
do you what that's only fans
only fans you can run it up not my
points yeah I don't know about that uh I
don't think I just letting that fly
Twitter though Twitter you could do
anything flies on Twitter
is a dark place I have I had Twitter in
like two years yeah my wife recently
went through my Twitter followers uh
people I was following and she uh she
wasn't happy she erased it well she was
just like who did I marry why is
everyone you follow have XXX in their
bio and I was like uh I've had Twitter
since 09 babe
bro it used to be dangerous when I would
like open my laptop yeah and like
twitter'd be up I can't like I
unfollowed all the porn [ __ ] but it
used to just be smut my whole timeline
was just [ __ ] up porn just like I
would just follow my favorite porn stars
bro yeah
yeah facts
it's great who's your favorite artist
right now
artists new yeah from a city
I really like the siete kid a lot oh my
God he came up here and like we had a
dope convo I think he's got potential to
make like some really big records he got
a good head on the shoulders man he does
and I really like Ruchi that's my little
brother Ruchi to me has uh he's he's
dope I think his personality is great he
just walks around with a bong and will
just like light up a bong like a big
bong like you know like most people
don't travel with a bong they'll be like
I got back no this [ __ ] has a
four foot bong with him at all times I
love Ruchi I think Richie's fire them
Joe Moses kids though you know everybody
got their sex in the kids Ruchi Lil
Deuce dope them Joe Moses kids like them
them kids that listen to Joe Moses and
and came up to be somebody in life you
know what I'm saying so then was my then
was my babies right there when I when I
mean by that I love you I mean you
mentioned one take Jay one take Jay's
dope I love it that's a little bro
um one take Jay one take Quan the whole
one take I used to have him around me
for months I used to take him to the
clubs like yeah trike is dope um then
was all supposed to be nwb artists and
in reality we did a whole mixtape and I
wanted to sign them I just didn't have
my business and [ __ ] right at that time
but I did a whole take with them
um like me blue boxes dope I like Rambo
I try to sign blue books too they'll
tell you they signed with Louis Tate I
mean you know what I'm saying Louis Tate
doing this thing
yeah and they know I'm for the city man
I ain't going against nothing in the
city period Point Blank I don't got
nothing bad to say about nobody in the
city I'm for the city and I stand on
that I never get on this [ __ ] and and on
on the platform and disrespect nobody in
the city game just dropped this album
Happy game drop this album airplane
James is dope who airplane he's dope oh
yeah okay yeah yeah yeah he is three but
I
he been around though yeah he's been
around but I mean he's been he's been
doing his thing lately
uh yeah man I mean
I like I mean there's a kid named Rob
with a back Chaser that's a Mexican
rapper that's pretty hard for me I miss
him he's cool he's going on he's going
on tour with somebody yeah yeah they're
going on a little joints listen
a a z sway I had him around me
2011 2012. you know that's what I'm
saying that's crazy I like that that he
was supposed to be my artist 2012. I was
going crazy with him taking this record
I had Chris Brown and Ty Dolla Sign on
his remix of his song yeah and we just
he just went off and did his own thing
but I bet I've been uh I've been one of
the biggest anars in the city I've been
one of the guys that come get all the
youth like you know what I'm saying what
I'm saying like I got the remix with
with zo Osama
shout out to him you know what I'm
saying he had a high record come on
gotta keep it going 100 who else on your
album you told me gun is on the album
Ish what's up so gunning is on the album
but I took him off you took him off yeah
because it's the just the my brother and
you know I'm saying I already had his
blessings four years ago on the records
him and Thug I just took him off because
I'm like
I'm so man I'm so like above it and I
and I don't want nobody to feel like I'm
using that situation like he to help
your music to help my nah bro they're my
brothers I'm saying like I got it I got
songs with them right when they get out
we gonna put our music out you know I'm
saying they will get out you know it
feels like that they should get out
because I feel like what people aren't
really uh not to be in the business of
like their case or anything but what I
think people have a misconception is
that it's a Georgia State Rico not a fed
Rico it's not yet at least but the FED
Rico is the one where it's like yeah yo
so so so if it's a state of Georgia and
it's that lady that that prosecuted from
that county that put together the RICO
case so it's not not saying that's not
serious it's obviously very serious but
you would hope that like you know things
will get cleared up yeah so
man listen man you can't police are
[ __ ] crazy though the fact that
they're I'm glad that California is at
least a safe haven for artists to speak
freely in their music because I think
they just passed that out here where you
can't [ __ ] with people off of song
lyrics come on man we're talking about
art
yeah but sometimes your art can turn
into another person's reality so you got
to watch what you say in the in these
music sometime well I was about to say
would you because would you advise that
because I feel like artists who we know
are probably certain types of
individuals
you listen to the music and you're like
damn it sounds like you're snitching on
yourself okay that's nice
some some people are snitching like some
people are dry dry on their self yeah
you got to watch what you say in this
[ __ ] so like I say it's [ __ ] that I
signed up for it's like I know I gotta
watch what I say it's like certain [ __ ]
you just I'm just like yo I'm a factor
where I come from so it's like
Little Joe I'm not I'm not speaking I'm
speaking all Joe Moses times I ain't
know no Little Joe times because Little
Joe was a different type of individual
somebody else who uh is a function guy
who somehow when I was first moving to
La had stunt doubles because he was at
every nightclub all at the same time
someone you grew up with A.D yeah a
smart kid uh
yeah well I mean I I know you guys you
grew up at each other's families houses
and I raised him my kids how proud are
you to see him do his thing and like his
personality is like I hate A.D wife me
too really I just hate his teeth I love
ad that [ __ ] got them he got no
problem being caught on the car I love
A.D so because he's he's he's he's he's
turned into somebody that's consistent
on his passion and what he want to do
and his character I feel like he's he's
being in the position he's in is easy
for him to do it like he's done zero
[ __ ] [ __ ] he don't have no flaw
character in him even though even when I
want to be mad at him like he like Joe
still my big bro so [ __ ] y'all I don't
give a [ __ ] oh and whatever we go he's a
great guy man no ad listen and I'm
telling you that right here on bootleg
Kev I'm proud of you bro I'm proud of
you I'm proud of Genesis I'm proud of
pun
um I'm proud of
um a lot of people that came a part of
our situation
um that was that was around with us AV
I'm product av's dope yeah I'm proud of
Av AV to me is like similar to you in
terms of like yeah I just got slappers
yeah like when AV dropped some [ __ ] he
know what he doing he I I ain't like
yeah a lot of people you don't get
enough respect a lot of people came
about the conversation you know what I'm
saying with AV I definitely deal with a
I mean I definitely deal with AV Force
like
like AV was one of them guys where it
was like you couldn't go to a function
where they wasn't playing Joe Moses YG
and AV yeah money dance is a car man you
know what I'm saying and I'm talking I'm
talking about 2008 2009 2010. for sure
you couldn't like people people come up
here and don't speak reality you
couldn't go to a function and they
wasn't playing Joe Moses uh uh uh AV
YG and who else
um who else who else was the little dude
that uh that was from Long Beach day of
third KF third say up today was playing
tail third back then
problem you know what I'm saying the
problem run but that was that was after
us though the welcome to Molly World now
see that well he just celebrated the
10-year anniversary of
no that was but but also people forget
problem was around then problem was
around here no no bro problem had what's
the name back then he had um I'm [ __ ]
up I'm [ __ ] up yeah before you had
that that was like oh 809 yeah well I'm
talking about when we was doing that
probably had um I'm [ __ ] up yeah he
was already he was already on a bigger
stage than us yeah probably he was
already traveling you know what I'm
saying he was already traveling going
around the world on the biggest stage
than us you know I'm talking about in
the basements uh in them parties in the
basements Costco
but I met you remember the Thai song
All-Star that was my [ __ ] yeah that was
yeah that [ __ ] was a classic
we was really in a dungeon I'm talking
about in the dungeons in them dungeon
functions
functions them dungeon function where
it's hot you gotta take your shirt off
everybody in there freaking when you
hear uh uh t-shirt my panties come on
and then YG relax come on oh it used to
go crazy I used to tell Ty bro you don't
see how these women treat you I wish I
can sing he used to sing relaxing the
girls oh my yeah I was like wow this is
crazy bro like we we really Superstars
and really don't know it I should
perform at bar mitzvahs Jesus backyard
back since backyard boogies
got to be wonderful bro I perform
everywhere I was Jumbo's everywhere bro
and it had a lot to do with me just
showing up even when I know we wasn't
invited as my husband we should just
show up we gotta stop the interview tell
you about our partners at Odd Socks well
first of all let's check out the brand
new collab
look at this the bootleg capsock you see
my pink ass face on those [ __ ] socks
nobody wants to buy those we're gonna
figure out a way to give them away
though uh but look Odd Socks the most
comfortable socks in the world
um and the best thing about Odd Socks is
they're our family man I've been rocking
with these guys for about 10 years now
and I will not wear anything else on my
feet like I swear to God I'm about to
take my shoe off I'm about to take the
look what is this
smells great too that's an odd sock
right there that's an odd sock basic you
know what I'm saying we [ __ ] with Odd
Socks you should too they got the crazy
licenses we're talking about Nickelodeon
shout out to Patrick [ __ ]
Cheez-Its Baywatch
how about macaroni underwear look at
these boys right here let's just crack
these [ __ ] open real quick what
do we got in here
come on man
yeah a little Pop-Tart underwear you
know what I mean yeah these are the Odd
Socks Basics all right so if you go to
the website right now order you some
underwear order you some socks use the
promo code bootleg Kev that's one word
altogether bootleg Kev and you will save
20 off at checkout go to
oddsocksofficial.com one more time
that's oddsocksofficial.com promo code
bootleg Kev and you will save 20 off
your order of course represented by Odd
Socks and we are proud to say so all
right let's get back to the interview
real quick uh
give me the story behind the title of
the project from nothing to something
full it's just legendary it's really my
life coming from nothing to some you
know jumping out here you know straight
from prison jumping into the booth and
really becoming some successful Big Y
and wacko always believed you know what
I'm saying
um my team believing in me and that's
just the whole story my dad always you
tell me bro you got a son you gotta from
none of some story like you always gonna
be the guy that's from none of some like
my celly in prison lonely man you should
be like bro from then to some Little Joe
when you get out you're gonna become
somebody so I really take that [ __ ]
serious it's like it's like my longevity
is is not heading straight to space it's
just floating in the sky and then going
to space a lot of these kids go straight
to space and then get lost and get lost
in the sauce and then they got to come
back down to earth I've been the most
consistent you should they should give
me the award for just the most
consistent these last couple of years
I've had hit songs hit records and I put
out the most consistent records over the
years and I'm still here dealing with
all the young guys I'm still here to
watch blue books I'm still here to watch
blast I'm still here watch Kailyn I'm so
proud of Kalin Kayla's killing it and
he's also you mentioned earlier he's got
a gray hat on his shoulders great dude
yeah Wally I'm so proud of all these
artists I've seen that I've seen from a
long time and now I get to like be the
Big Homie and get to give him gang like
okay bro boom boom boom do this and they
still respect me like Damn Joe about to
drop out on that [ __ ] crazy you know
what I'm saying that's future type [ __ ]
just not on a bigger scale future is
just on the future's on a bigger scale
right yeah I'm saying like Future's
still around he was around with the
dungeon family thinking about it no I I
always like whenever I interview future
that's the first thing I'm like yo tell
me about your dungeon family because
people don't realize Future Has Dungeon
Family tatted on his [ __ ] forums and
that's my brother one thing about future
Mo he'd be so hot at me
you know I don't want to enter in in the
interview like that they'd be so mad at
me like what you doing
bro you taking too many breaks like you
got to stay on it bro I'm on it this
time good I got the right team you say
you got 70 missiles right here I got 70
missiles DJ cheeseburger got missiles he
gonna drop and then my artist C4 gonna
drop he got the whole thing coming out
with London on the track we just did a
joint venture with him and he's happy me
and London shout out to my brother
London man you know I love you we've
been down since we was with Waka Flocka
and Gucci man he's a ghost he's a goat
like you know what I'm saying I ain't a
goat yet I'm a baby goat baby yo you
could be a baby girl like Luca Luca's a
baby goat look at what Luka donkic from
the Mavericks that's a baby goat baby go
yeah I'm a baby goat I'll take that
there it is man you already know what's
up man Joe Moses my guy I appreciate you
brother yes sir yes sir boom